the Ukrainian counter-offensive has been
going on since June ever since then
we've been hearing vested different
things from both sides according to the
pro-russian crowd the Ukrainian
counter-offensive has been a complete
failure Western weapons are ineffective
and the Russian landscape holding
according to the pro-ukrainian
cheerleaders the Ukrainian
counter-offensive is going exactly
according to plan and the Russian lines
are two days away from complete collapse
but in this case both extremes are wrong
in this video I'll be talking about the
following the description of the basic
situation the problems Russia and
Ukraine are facing the current status of
the counter-offensive a word on
pro-russian quote-unquote peace
Advocates a rough Outlook into the
future in terms of how and when the war
could end and accounts you should and
shouldn't follow for accurate coverage
and I'll be doing all this in the Peru
format because it's the most practical
you should definitely subscribe to perun
by the way the link to his channel is in
the description so let's get started but
first I'd like to thank conflict of
Nations for sponsoring today's video
conflict of Nations is a free online
player versus player strategy game where
you get to choose a real country to lead
during World War 3 you can battle up to
128 players in games that can last up to
multiple weeks use a wide array of
military units ranging from tanks Jets
to nuclear submarines declared war on
other players or Forge alliances with
them engaging battles and craft your own
strategy to take over the world conflict
of Nations is playable both on PC and
mobile with the same account click my
link in the description and get 13 000
gold and one month of Premium
subscription for free the offer is
available for 30 days only so don't
waste time thank you once again for
conflict of Nations for sponsoring
today's video and now back to the
program so let's start with the basic
summary of the situation in Ukraine how
goes the counter-offensive I believe we
can all see by now that this is it
hargiv or the first weeks of the
invasion this is like Harrison but much
worse there are no quick gains or
astounding successes just a slow bloody
grind through Russian lines one trench
at a time these aren't your history duck
trenches either like in the beginning
these are formidable more or less
well-built fortifications where soldiers
can often survive even a direct hit for
artillery these trenches were built in
the framework of the original sort of
vacant plan built out fortifications
wait are the winter while reconstituting
let ukrainians crash against defenses
then attack them once exhausted this was
the plan for the winter but Russian
political machinations forced an attack
instead they took buckmut at an almost
catastrophic cost and ground themselves
down atar the result is an exhausted
Russian army and reconstituted Ukrainian
forces the opposite of what sorovicin
wanted but the defenses are still there
and formidable bad Russian decision
making did not win the war for
ukrainians it only gave them an
advantage but Ukraine is also in a Time
press the ground is maneuverable till
October when the rasputita hits meaning
as of the making of this video they have
about two months for maneuvering high
intensity combat as a disclaimer though
I'd like to stress that we do not know
what the Ukrainian plans are we can only
speculate and extrapolate but in the
meantime only the Ukrainian leadership
knows what they can and want to achieve
and when please keep this in mind as we
go along and now let's take a look at
factors like what each side is doing and
the problems they are facing first the
ukrainians you you might have noticed
that despite the cheerleader's
insistence the counter-offensive did not
start out as well as expected before his
official start there was a large social
media campaign by Ukraine which made it
seem like they will break through
Russian defenses and be at the Sea of
azovan about a month but Russian
defenses proved far harder to correct
than expected we all remembered that
blown out color of Bradleys which
Russian propaganda took thousands of
pictures of from every possible angle
and kept spamming them in social media
for weeks that was a failed Ukrainian
attempt at breaking through a Russian
defensive line but thankfully that was
the last of such an occasion Ukrainian
command quickly realized that they won't
break through Russian lines head-on so
they adapted now instead of head-on
mechanized assaults they use artillery
to soften impression defenses and high
Mars to interdict Russian supplies
blowing up the Carriage Bridge yet again
was part of this strategy with this the
ukrainians are chipping away at Russian
Hill territory bit by bit slowly making
progress as for ukrainian's problems the
first is the usual suspect the lack of
shells this problem is being remedied
but it takes time to ramp up production
and establish supply lines still we have
come a long way since last year where
the Ukrainian shell stocks were
catastrophic levels another problem a
reason for Ukraine's slow progress is
the lack of experience in large scale
combined arms Maneuvers this is pretty
much the most difficult thing an army
can do and ukrainians have to learn it
in a few months while they are actively
at War consequently they opted for an
arterly supported incremental Advance
instead alright you might say but does
NATO Doctrine and training help yes and
no it does help in the sense that the
troops did get NATO training and are
using more and more NATO standard
vehicles and equipment and it does not
help in the sense that they only got
basic short-termed NATO training in
addition when breaching defensive lines
while large-scale combiners Maneuvers
are difficult enough to pull off NATO
Doctrine also assumes Air Supremacy is a
basic prerequisite which is in the case
here the airspace is contested and
Russian ka52 helicopters can freely lob
anti-tank guided missiles at advancing
Ukrainian columns from well outside air
defense range this problem cannot be
solved simply by having a gap art
short-range anti-air gun accompanying
troops despite what certain build
journalists on Twitter would want you to
believe the overarching issue ukrainians
are facing is that there Russian
military Exiles in so-called defense in
depth if there is one thing they can do
extremely well it's this Russians have
multiple defensive lines for 30 40 50
kilometers in depth and they are not
about to give them up without a fight so
how does Western Equipment factor into
this they do help and are very important
but the main most important form of Aid
remains artillery shells that being said
Western Equipment such as Bradleys and
leopards tend to arrive in delayed
shipments in smaller than needed
quantities the stuff Ukraine is getting
now has been agreed upon last year in
December 2022 zalushini said that he
needed 300 tanks 700 infantry fighting
vehicles and 500 howitzers in order to
get back to the 23rd of February borders
not Crimea not the dumbass the 23rd of
February borders in contrast at the time
of recording Ukraine received around 60
leopard twos and 14 Challengers so 74
modern tanks in addition to 40 Martyrs
and the 154 Bradleys so 194 modern ifvs
so by the time of the country offensive
Ukraine received about a fourth of
what's needed as a bare minimum and we
haven't even talked about things like 16
Jets Ukraine will be able to deploy
those in 2024 at best meanwhile they
needed them already in June 2023 with
all that said how is Russia faring along
stopping the counter-offensive is the
task of the Russian land forces who
according to estimates have lost 40 to
50 percent of their personal to death or
injury through the worst 17 months so
the Ukrainian counter-offensive is faced
off by heavily at treated Russia
military however despite their attrition
there are still a lot of them in Ukraine
with their fortifications acting as a
force multiplier on the other hand
Russian equipment losses have been and
continue to be somewhere between
catastrophic and severe as they continue
to speed during the destruction of their
Soviet Heritage currently Russia's
visually confirmed losses stand at 11
533 of which 2199 are tanks 938 armored
fighting Vehicles 2616 ifvs 339 apcs and
139 imvs all this is to say Russia won't
be conducting maneuver-based defense
their current task is to hold the lines
at all costs and try to iterate
Ukrainian attackers and they do this
with varying degrees of success as of
the making of this video ukrainians have
managed to take over the first
preliminary Russian trench lines north
of tokmag and are gradually progressing
South they have yet to reach the main
Russian lines which will be the true
test for both sides the challenge Russia
is facing in the meantime are The Usual
Suspects low morale at treated supply
lines and the treated formations none of
these three has reached critical levels
yet and there is no 100 guarantee that
any of them will but time will tell now
a question on some people's minds might
be how does Wagner factor into this the
mercenary Army led by Afghani pregosian
well ever since their Rebellion Wagner
troops have been mostly withdrawn from
Ukraine some of them left lognet and
joined the Russian army instead but many
also stayed in Belarus as military
trainers despite many Wagner soldiers
staying to fight in Ukraine I don't
think they will represent much of a
threat the Wagner group was the
strongest in its intact form with its
well-established experienced formations
post fracture they won't influence the
war as much other than numerically
bolstering some Russian formations with
all that in mind let's take a look at
how the Contour offensive is going most
of the action is happening in the south
of Ukraine namely the zapore region this
is where the main effort is and will be
most likely as I've said here Russian
lines are up to 50 kilometers deep with
multiple lines of Defense as of now
ukrainians haven't even reached the
first line they're fighting in the
contested zones before that which is a
10 to 15 kilometer wide strip along the
front line they took over some trenches
but those aren't exactly the first line
of defense despite the cheerleaders
insistence here I'd like to emphasize
again that we don't know what the actual
Ukrainian battle plans are we don't know
what the ukrainians want to accomplish
in what time frame take those destroyed
Bradleys and leopards which Russian
State media photographed from every
angle multiple times we don't know what
their task was we have no idea we can
guess we can even guess well but that's
the most we can do did ukrainians plan
on breaking through Russian lines
quickly could be maybe likely but we
don't know so far ukrainians only seem
to be poking at Russian defense lines
and exploiting the occasional openings
when ukrainians detect a weak point they
reinforce the area hoping to exacerbate
the situation for Russians potentially
leading to a breakthrough that is
coupled with artillery barrages and
supply line interdictions for greater
effect so far we've only seen smaller
progresses mostly around
origa however ukrainians also haven't
stopped advancing around bug mode aiming
to envelop the city and force the
Russians to abandon it in fact around
Bach mood Russians have really been on
the back foot lately current Ukrainian
advances remain small measured in
villages but even such small gains end
up over time and Ukraine still hasn't
deployed the bulk of its
counter-offensive forces clearly they
are waiting for a different opportunity
that being said Don't expect Crimea to
be taking back this year despite what
some cheerleaders might say it'll be
difficult enough to cut the Russian
language to karimea let alone taking the
peninsula itself a more reasonable goal
for the time being is the recapture of
territories controlled before the 23rd
of February once that comes within Arm's
Reach we can start talking about the Don
blessing Crimea in terms of the
counter-offensive and here I'd also like
to briefly mention hairson some people
might ask now that the novaka of God Dam
has collapsed and the reservoir is
drained will this enable some sort of
Ukrainian amphibious assault for example
on this operation nuclear power plant my
answer is I don't think so though the
story looks dry and cracked underneath
is very much soft and moist an armored
vehicle would sink into that in no time
aside from that ukrainians would have to
cross a huge open in space with a large
river flowing through the middle they
would still need to cross the river but
this time without any cover on its banks
so I don't think Ukraine is seriously
considering an amphibious assault at the
moment I should add I could be wrong of
course but so far this seems unlikely so
what should we expect in the war going
forward it is my impression that
ukrainians went into the country
offensive a bit too confident but then
after some equipment losses they revised
their strategy this was the correct move
compared to the Russian way of beating
their head against the wall in bhagmat
and we are still not in the main phase
of the counter-offensive the main forces
haven't been deployed yet and ukrainians
so far are only poking the Russian lines
looking for weaknesses and exploiting
local opportunities all this being said
even though progress might be slow
Russians can't just sit back and relax
they are taking significant losses both
personal and Equipment the latter taken
from a very much finite and fast
drinking Soviet era stockpile to give
you an idea we have the bare minimum
Baseline of visually confirmed losses by
oryx which was 15 thanks for the first
week of the country offensive the
Ukrainian government's claim for
destroyed Russian tanks meanwhile was
76. of course you should take the better
with a big grain of salt usually the
truth is closer to the oryx numbers but
then on the ninth day of the country
friend saved the 13th of June Vladimir
Putin stated that Russia has only lost
53 tanks compared to the hundreds of
tanks in ifbs Ukraine has lost of course
that letter is ridiculous but the former
is very interesting Putin's 53 figure is
significantly closer to the Ukrainian
government number than to the oryx
number this potentially shows that a lot
of losses go visually undocumented and
that Russian losses are more severe than
we thought recently in visually
confirmed losses t-80 tanks started
overtaking t-72 tanks and the lost tanks
are increasingly older meaning Russia is
slowly running out of t-72s and more
modern tanks in general despite the West
being Frugal and somewhat reluctant with
deliveries so far given enough time they
can definitely outmatch Russian
production and stockpiles so the phrase
time is on Russia's side is not
necessarily accurate another point with
regards to Western Equipment going back
to the failed Ukrainian push that saw
the destruction and abandonment of
multiple Bradleys and leopards key night
viewers might notice an important detail
the vehicle's doors are open and there
are no corpses around despite being hit
by mines at artillery it seems like the
vehicles protected the soldiers who left
the scene on their own if this Jose
column of russian-made vehicles most of
those soldiers would have been dead
despite losses Western Equipment helped
save soldiers lives thus preserving
Ukraine's strength the same cannot be
said about the Russian military and
their equipment this is another factor
in Ukraine's favor borrowing some major
unforeseen event or events I believe
this is how the country offensive will
chug along for a long time not as rapid
sweeping advances by either side but as
a slow brutal attritional War where the
Ukraine slowly chips away at Russian
Health territory the question then
becomes who breaks first or gets so
exhausted they'll be forced to sit down
at the negotiating table still these are
very much future considerations the war
will drag on well into next year so
first let's just get there and then
we'll go from there in the meantime
Russians continue being demons and human
skin as soon as they cancel the grain
agreement they started bombarding
Ukrainian green storage facilities with
grain men for African countries this was
followed by hits on Harrison public
transit a messiah strike on a
residential Block in pokrovs and other
choice war crimes to those who have been
paying attention to Russian military
actions for a while now this is nothing
new in Aleppo Syria they specifically
targeted hospitals and raised hair
photos into the ground in Ukraine the
mood of separenti Remains the Same if
they have to Rocket strike civilian
energy infrastructure hospitals and food
storages they will do so if they have to
launch thousands of cluster mutations
indiscriminately on Ukrainian cities
then that's what they're going to do for
this reason pay no attention to the
handwringing and concerned trolling of
the quote-unquote peace activists who
only started having problems with say
cluster Munitions once Ukraine got them
the same goes for the carriage Russia
can spend months hammering Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure with missiles
and we don't hear a peep from peace
Advocates but once Ukraine hits the
Carriage Bridge with a sea drone well
how dare the ukrainians target civilian
infrastructure which the catch Bridges
not by the way it's a military logistics
artery therefore a legitimate Target if
there are Russian civilians on the
bridge well they are on Ukrainian
territory on an unauthorized structure
where the Ukrainian government forbade
entry if you still decide to go despite
all this and get caught in an explosion
I don't know what to tell you so when
you encounter the aforementioned peace
activists who seem to only ever have a
problem with something when Ukraine does
it remember for them it was never about
peace or Justice they don't care they
never did and they never will whether
the peace Advocate is on the far left or
the far right it doesn't matter their
one and only consistent position is that
they want Russia to win period now let's
talk about how the world could
theoretically end it all depends on the
situation on the battlefield on which
side can achieve what in what time frame
I believe the current range of
possibilities is between the full
liberation of Ukraine on one hand and
the North and South Korea situation on
the other the full Liberation scenario
is self-explanatory Ukraine returns to
its 1991 borders with Don best and
Crimea return to the country as for the
Korea scenario that could mean something
like the solidification of front lines
and the cessation of hostilities held up
by a 10-year ceasefire agreement as a
reminder there is no real peace
agreement between the two careers to
this day if this happens with Ukraine
the front lines turn into a type of
demilitarized zone the Ukrainian
military gets fully outfitted with
Western Equipment and then we'll go from
there I believe these are the two
extremes currently on the table but of
course this might change with time it
all depends on the number of factors
many of which cannot be foreseen but if
ukrainians figure out to combine arms
Maneuvers at scale and are better able
to break through Russian lines this will
increase the chances of the so-called
good ending in the meantime you can also
start playing conflict of Nations a free
online PVP strategy game in a world of
modern Global Warfare choose your
strategy engage in large-scale battles
and take over the world in the process
get an exclusive gift of 13 000 gold and
one month of Premium subscription for
free the offer is available for 30 days
only so don't waste time click my link
in the description choose your country
and fight your way to Victory and now as
promised here are some people you can
and should follow if you want an
accurate unbiased coverage of the war in
Ukraine these would be Death Moon
tatarigami underscore UA Michael Goffman
robley OS end underscore East OS in
Technical warmapper and special herzon
cat of course this list isn't exhaustive
in contrast here are some accounts to
avoid at all costs if you want accurate
coverage of the war in Ukraine war
monitor trentelenco Igor sushko and
Chuck Farrer once again these are the
ones you should avoid alright so this
was my Ukraine encounter offensive
update as of the first half of August I
hope you found it informative and
enjoyable I'll be putting out another
Ukraine update next year the earliest
unless something big happens in the
meantime thank you for watching and see
you next time